"La semaine dernière,"
"les candidats de Top Wesh
sont allés de surprise en surprise."
Ouais vas-y, bienvenue.
-Bonjour Wesh
"ls ont d'abord tenté d'impressionner"
"notre jury de weshs étoilés"
"en se posant dans le tromé."
Ben franchement Bastien,
j'y ai cru, t'as fait le taf et tout
mais après ...
erreur de boloss.
Parce qu'un vrai wesh,
qu'il soit dans le bus,
sur un scooter,
y'a pas de casque,
il respecte rien!
Désolé wesh.
T'excuse pas!
"Dans l'épreuve de rattrapage,"
"Guillaume, Elodie,
Bastien et David"
"vont tout donner en accostant une fille"
"à la manière des plus grands weshs. "
Franchement, j'étais pas à l'aise
en tant que fille.
C'était pas une épreuve pour moi.
He, he, viens voir! Viens me voir!
Eh, franchement
t'es fraiche j'avoue.
Heureusement David
il a vraiment fait le bouffon.
Euh, c'est pas grave,
bonne journée!
"Un faux pas qui lui coutera
sa place dans l'aventure. "
Ah, Putain!
On arrive à un stade de la compétition
où on peut plus se permettre
de laisser passer des erreurs pareilles.
Aujourd'hui dans Top Wesh,
nos candidats vont devoir rivaliser
de créativité et d'inventivité
puisqu'ils s'apprêtent à revisiter
l'un des grands classiques Wesh,
le survet Tacchini.
Guillaume, comment vous allez aborder
cette épreuve alors?
Alors je pensais partir sur
une belle paire de Nike Requins,
je vais la sublimer
avec une paire de chaussettes Lotto
pour jouer sur la connaissance des classiques.
-D'accord.
Perdez pas de temps Guillaume hein.
-Ouais ça va, vas-y, vas-y.
Ehh, tu fais quoi là?
Euh, là j'allais partir sur peut être...
Baisse pas les yeux,
baisse pas les yeux,
t'es une baltringue ou quoi?
Pardon wesh.
-T'excuse pas putain!
T'es un bonhomme
ou t'es une fillette?
J'suis un bonhomme.
Un bonhomme, voilà,
lève la tête,
lève la tête.
Vas-y, fais.
La ceinture Gucci
des Puces de Saint Ouen
est un produit que
j'ai l'habitude de travailler,
je vais partir là-dessus.
J'avoue, j'ai ajouté
un ingrédient mystère,
mais je dis pas c'est quoi
jsuis pas une poucave.
Les gars,
marier la visière Lacoste
et la sacoche Vuitton d'Elodie,
franchement c'est malin.
Moi j'aime bien.
Comme on me reproche souvent
mon agressivité ...
Vas-y j'arrive pas à la mettre là.
Nique ta mère
J'vai la jouer en finesse
avec un trait de rasoir dans le sourcil
et après je vais dresser mon haut de survet
façon"Back to fragile".
Eh ben voilà,
il a voulu faire original
mais il a rien compris.
Il s'est ficha de ouf.
Allez, plus que quelques secondes ...
J'avais pris une banane.
Putain elle est où la banane?
Qui c'est qui l'a pris la banane?
Arrête s'il te plait.
Guillaume, on essaye de ne pas se faire bolosser
par le temps cette fois ...
Allez, on finit, on finit vite.
on se dépêche,
et ...
Top c'est fini,
tout le monde lève les mains.
Voilà quoi, dans le speed,
je me suis précipité
et j'ai fait un trou de boulette
dans mon polo Lacoste, t'as vu.
J'espère que le jury va pas trop me victimiser,
tu vois?
L'épreuve de tous les défis
et de toutes les audaces,
c'est ce soir, dans Top Wesh.
A suivre, sur M6,
un nouveau numéro de
«Wesh toute nue».